just like in Dark Souls 1 & 2 you can
also turn into a dragon in Dark Souls 3
first and foremost you're going to have
to make your way to a thorough boreal
valley next to make your way to the 8th
roll dungeon traverse the dungeon until
you get to this area where you'll see a
dragon shaped statue meditating here
you'll gain the dragon torso in order to
get the dragon head you'll need to gain
the path of the dragon emo in an area
right past the consumed King to get to
the consumed King you'll need to make
your way past the boreal valley dancer
once you defeat her you can place the
basin near the statue behind her and the
latter will descend once you do that
take the path to the left where the
consumed King is
once you defeat the consumed King walk
down the hallway and next to a basin
you'll see a fallen soldier who will
have the path of the Dragon emo head
back to where you got the dragon torso
once there use the path of the dragon
emo next to the statue you'll then be
teleported to a new secret area here
you'll have to make your way past a few
enemies until you reach this gate once
you reach the gate you'll be greeted by
an ancient wyvern defeat the wyvern and
you'll receive the dragon head
for additional dragon fun go ahead and
progress through the area until you
reach this coffin here you can use the
path of the Dragon II mode again and
gain the twinkling dragon torso which
will give you access to an additional
move and dragon form now that you've
acquired the twinkling dragon torso you
can also acquire the twinkling dragon
head in order to do this you're going to
have to go back to the fire link shine
exhaust your dialog options with
hawkwood the deserter if you haven't
already the next time you leave the
shrine and come back talk to the
blacksmith who has been given a message
by Hawkwood turns out he's in the
Dragons as well meet him where you
fought the abyss Watchers he's going to
want your twinkling dragon torso loathe
me all you like I shall take what makes
you Dragon by defeating him you'll gain
the twinkling dragon head however if you
lose he'll take the twinkling dragon
torso from you you can still get both
pieces back by defeating him though
now take off all your armor and morph
into a dragon
here's some of the base moves including
a flame breath and a battlecry that
increases damage the twinkling dragging
the headpiece will give you access to a
larger flame breath from a huge dragon
head and the twinkling torso will give
you a strong slam with two large dragon
claws enjoy being a dragon dragon form
will persist until death and you can
enter the dragon state again if you
choose to stay tuned to gain SWAT comm
for more Dark Souls 3 secrets and tips